counterfeit money is an important weapon
of The Saboteur throw time counterfeit
currency has played a vital role in the
history of the United States to banks
and other financial institutions Secret
Service offers instruction and how to
detect spurious money there are always
menu differences obvious to the trained
eye which make detection possible since
the Secret Service inception they have
worked tirelessly to suppress
counterfeit currency
[Music]
a lot of people are unaware that the
United States Secret Service was formed
during the Civil War in response to the
rising counterfeit currency that was
being printed by the Confederate Army
and distributed in the north when we
talk about counterfeit currency what
we're talking about isn't something that
you print at home we're talking about a
very high level artistic formation of
Federal Reserve notes notes that are so
undetectable to the common person and
they're very often times not even picked
up in banks during World War two Hitler
and the Nazis tried the same methodology
they forced Jewish artisans to create
counterfeit currency to try to
destabilize the US dollar globally all
of those attempts failed they're experts
in genuine currency so they were able to
secure the Treasury and the US financial
institutions from this impact of
counterfeit currency in major financial
regions in the United States hundreds of
thousands of dollars of counterfeit
currency are seized every week the role
of the Secret Service is to suppress
that counterfeit count and ensure that
those bills don't continue circulating
through the US economy incorporated into
every Federal Reserve Note are certain
security features some of those security
features are main classified in our
closely guarded secrets of the US
government here we're looking at a 20
and 100 dollar Federal Reserve Note both
have watermarks that are printed into
the paper itself process that's
developed when the paper stock is made
and it's embedded into the fibers it's
not a print it's actually an imprint
into the paper itself additionally a
common feature that is seen with the
naked eye is present in the lower right
hand corner of the 20 in the 100 dollar
bill and it's called optical varying ink
its image shifting ink that changes
color as the bill moves micro printing
is fine fine artistic work that's
embedded in the the genuine plate what
that means is you can't take a bill and
photocopy it and have it have the same
quality in the microwave in ting it'll
come through as just a straight line
that's a key indicator that it would be
a counterfeit bill one feature on the
$100 bill if you look very finely
printed on the lapel of Franklin his
microprinting it says the United States
of America very hard to see with the
naked eye but under magnification
it's another security feature and
finally embedded are colored fibers red
blue and there's also some that glow
with UV lighting these are key
indicators of a genuine bill on the
higher denomination bills there's a 3d
hologram strip that's imprinted into the
fiber itself that is again another
indicator of a genuine bill every bill
from the one to the 100 has a serial
number that serial number for the secret
service is used as a tracking device we
know what genuine bills look like and we
know what their their serial number and
sequence are counterfeiters don't
necessarily so oftentimes a bill that
does not follow a specific sequence are
a key indicator of a counterfeit Federal
Reserve note every genuine Federal
Reserve Note is associated to a Federal
Reserve Bank that is indicated on the
bill via specific locations here
oftentimes counterfeiters don't align
the bill to the right Federal Reserve
Bank again a key indicator of a
counterfeit bill counterfeiters seek to
undermine the credibility of the US
financial system by just the sheer
manufacturing of counterfeit currency
the Secret Service mindful of the impact
of this has they've worked with the
Department of the Treasury to come up
with security standards that are
inherent in every bill